hugo et gabriel se prépare à partir pour
une course de 10 km mais ils ne sont pas
seuls en situation de handicap ils ont
besoin de leurs coéquipiers pour pousser
leurs joëlette sorte de fauteuil roulant
tout terrain et janet est donc un engin
à une roue qui permet d'emmener des
jeunes à mobilité réduite sur les routes
dans les forêts dans les montagnes dans
les collines il faut une personne qui
pousse une personne qui tire et ont fait
avancer l'âge et howlett et on se relaye
entre coureurs de participer à ces
événements sportifs en se dépassant et
de manière collective ça me paraît être
la meilleure manière pour apprendre à
vivre ensemble pour lui c'est super
intéressant parce que comme sa maladie
en soi c'est un manque d'énergie il sait
qu'il peut pas faire de sport qui peut
pas courir qui peut pas voilà des
déployer de force dans l'activité
sportive il est conscient que le fait
qu'on court pour lui ou concours avec
lui aux confins du vélo ça apporte de
l'énergie et ça apporte de l'énergie bas
financière et physique et mentale ses
membres habitués ou débutants de
l'association dunes d'espoir permettent
à des personnes handicapées de faire des
courses habituellement réservé aux
valides 35 kg a poussé c'est physique
mais ses accompagnateurs donc un
challenge faire sourire le pilote d'un
effort collectif puisque on se relaie
autour de la joélette avec le pilote et
qu'on arrive on part ensemble en
arrivant semble que c'est ça qui fait la
force de cet exercice on se dit que si
un dimanche matin on doit se lever pour
aller courir autant le faire
deux façons de façon joyeuse souvent
quand y'a pas le soleil on se dit que le
soleil il est là et dans nos coeurs dans
le coeur des enfants et dans leurs
sourires delà des sensations qui
plaisent aux pilotes
le sourire du jeune voyait le sourire du
jeune donne de l'énergie à tous les
coureurs on chante on crie on fait les
fous qui était super content il ya le
fait de faire part tient à d'un groupe
vous faites on voit il est parce qu il
court il ya tout le monde qu'il dit à
leo c'est beaucoup de bonheur une
activité de partage pour tous le monde
grâce à la joélette et qui se déroulent
tout au long de l'année dans les
yvelines et en dehors avec dunes
d'espoir